You might call this a
modern Cinderella story.
But in our story,
the glass sneakers don't
find one pair of feet
to wear them happily ever after.
Instead they become assets
which retain their value over time.
This modern retelling
is all about reselling.
There's no prince in this story,
but there are some very handsome profits.
Vestiaire Collective is
a luxury resale company
whose story began in 2009,
when a group of chic Parisians
decided to clean out their closets
and sell on what they
weren't wearing anymore.
Now the fashion resale market is booming.
And earlier this year,
Vestiaire collective achieved
a valuation of $1.7 billion
in its latest round of funding.
But this is not the only
resale success story.
Resale companies on both
sides of the Atlantic
are attracting investors
with a promise of new growth
from old clothes.
And between Vestiaire's
buyers and sellers is this
the authentication center,
and it's never been busier.
The whole year of 2020,
we've seen a hundred percent
growth on items being listed.
Just thinking about the sheer
scale of unused inventory
is just enormous.
It's time to examine
the unstoppable rise of fashion resale.
What we wear says a lot about who we are,
yet fashion is also a $2.5
trillion global industry
that touches everyone on earth.
I'm Imran Amed.
I first started trying to make
sense of the fashion business
15 years ago, as it was being
transformed by technology,
globalization and
shifting consumer values.
Now I'm on a journey to see
how fashion is recalibrating
amid the pandemic,
to balance profit with purpose.
This is the Business of Fashion show.
Join me to discover how fashion
shapes business, culture,
and identity,
and to meet the people
forging fashion's future.
Old is the new new.
While style setters have long embraced
the chicest vintage clothes,
and savvy shoppers search
thrift and secondhand stores
on the promise of originality
and self-expression,
online resale platforms
are facilitating a bonafide
buy, sell, buy, sell boom.
Luxury brands thrive on strict
control of distribution,
price and perception.
Yet some are now embracing
resale to recruit new customers
and deepen engagement with existing ones.
Right across the resale market,
the simplicity of transactions
combined with shifting customer values
means secondhand is taking up
more space in fashion closets
now and in the future,
as more and more of what we
love to wear is pre-loved.
And the sellers?
In the US alone, it is
estimated that 9 billion items
of clothing are left unworn.
According to BOF Insights,
secondhand fashion sales
in the United States
could top $67 billion by 2025.
Buyers are first and foremost
seeking value for items
for which they would not be
prepared to pay full price.
While sustainability ranks
only third as a reason
to purchase resale.
Sellers and investors cite
support of circularity
and the eco cred of reducing emissions,
energy and water use.
But should we really be
celebrating this as slow fashion
or is it just another quick fix?
Could reselling unwanted
items actually be accelerating
more first-hand consumption?
Drops in limited edition products
create urgency and scarcity,
with some resell prices
more than six times higher
than retail prices.
And how to be sure of real versus fake?
In the buzzy youth segment,
how to protect peer-to-peer
teenage traders
in exposed online communities?
Resale platforms must be vigilant,
on authenticity and safety,
while customers on both
sides of the transaction
should keep age old mottoes in mind:
'Caveat Emptor, Caveat Venditor',
let the buyer and the seller beware.
I'm on a train headed to Lille,
a few hours north of Paris.
It's here that Vestiaire Collective,
the luxury resale company,
has set up its authentication center
to verify that the
products it sells are real.
CEO Max Bittner showed me around.
This whole area in
Tourcoing was a massive part
of the garment industry,
which then obviously got hit very hard
with the whole outsourcing.
Right.
So the people here are super passionate,
but they also really love fashion.
It's really a fashion industry,
so we can actually attract
good authenticators,
people who've been in the industry.
In 2019, Max joined
Vestiaire Collective as CEO
from Lazada,
a Southeast Asian online shopping portal
acquired by Alibaba.
I mean,
the huge difference here with us
is the senior authenticators
and all the authenticators
get three months training,
which is very long.
And what's the training that's provided?
We have the experts who've come here,
whether they're from
auction houses or the like,
and you're speaking to
one of them in a second.
Right.
They basically go by brand, by category,
all the learnings that we've acquired
over the last 12 years.
And with a lot of the brands,
we've received also training from them.
I'm in charge of the authentication.
This is my seventh year
at Vestiaire Collective.
I come from fashion auctions.
A counterfeiter will always do a mistake.
And our job is to detect the mistake.
If there is a mistake, of
course, it's a counterfeit.
What's the most expensive item ever sold
on Vestiaire Collective?
The most expensive item ever sold was
an €85,000 Himalayan Birkin,
which was sold from a Hong Kong
seller to a New York buyer.
We actually had an incident two weeks ago
where someone bought a
250,000 golden Patek Philippe,
but the seller then didn't ship it,
so we were very sad about that.
But there have been
items close to €100,000,
bought and sold on the platform.
The lower price point,
the minimum basket size
you can sell is €15.
So you can't sell anything
which is below €15.
If you think about the average basket size
of some of these peer to peer platforms,
I think that is the average basket size.
So we clearly differentiate there.
And we try to limit what I
would call broadly fast fashion.
We don't really want to have fast fashion
and encourage fast
fashion on the platform.
Why not?
We have a positioning of
more higher end fashion,
real luxury, real designer,
something that people want to buy and sell
for a much longer period.
One of the key things in
the roles that we play,
as a secondhand platform,
is that we want to educate people
that what they buy and
sell is not consumables,
just fashion.
It's really an asset.
And if you think about the
way we, as a consumer class,
need to change the way we
think about consumption,
is that we need to take much better care
and appreciate the value
of the items that we have
because there is a residual value.
How do you respond to
that kind of criticism,
that the resell market
actually propagates consumption
as opposed to manages it or minimizes it?
I think that's probably the question
that concerns us the most
because I think as part
of our core mission,
we want to change consumer
behavior to the better.
And we've actually spent
quite a lot of time
with external agencies
to challenge ourselves.
And our goal is to be
carbon neutral by '25,
without any offsetting.
And we've looked through all our emission,
whether it's our transport
or the way that we reduce consumption
and we think that target
of being carbon neutral
without offsetting is possible.
The fact of the matter is,
we do reduce the amount people consume
because what we help them
to do is to trade up.
Instead of buying Zara firsthand,
they buy Sézane secondhand,
if buying Sézane firsthand,
they buy Yves Saint Laurent secondhand,
instead buying firsthand Chanel,
they buy secondhand Hermès.
So you basically go up the food chain
and we want to help and
educate every consumer
that they should maybe
pay a bit more upfront
for an item that they're
going to wear longer
and where they're more
likely to take care of it
and then resell it in the future.
You didn't come from this world.
You probably didn't even know
what a Himalaya Birkin was.
I used to climb the Himalayas, maybe,
but I didn't find any Birkins there.
No, I have to admit I'm a brute.
I think there would be
many people in the industry
who would probably still
roll their eyes at me.
And that's fine.
I made my career selling $6
dresses or $70 mobile phones
across Indonesia and Malaysia.
It's a very different business.
But in the end,
what we do is use technology
to connect buyers and sellers.
It's about customer service,
it's about user experience.
But the beautiful thing about
the products that we sell now,
and I've really gained
massive appreciation to it,
is there's real craftsmanship.
They're real pieces of art
and trying to educate people
of that underlying intrinsic
value of these items
and therefore making
people change towards,
what I think, is better consumption.
I mean is probably the most
fulfilling thing there is.
How has your customer behavior,
both in terms of sellers and buyers,
shifted over this period of disruption
that we've all been living through?
It's really allowed people
to be quite self-reflective
and to start asking themselves, okay,
what can I do myself to be different?
And secondhand is one
of these very few things
where people can do something today.
How do you manage that
tension around authenticity?
Because without authenticity,
this luxury focused operation
starts to teeter a bit.
If you step back on the
actual topic of fakes,
at the moment, one in
1000 products is fake.
So the chances of buying
something on Vestiaire
and it not being authentic is one in 1000.
Is that perfect? No, it's not perfect.
And we're by no means nearly done
on what we can do to improve it.
Coming back to the customers,
we have this incredibly engaged community.
And the beauty about secondhand is
that people really define their own style.
They can shop back decades to
find what they're looking for.
They can find products
that they might not be able to look for.
I mean, we often think the world is Paris,
the world is London,
the world is New York,
but we have access to people, to products,
that would never get access
to anywhere in the world.
So it's really about this
global digital wardrobe,
which gives access to products
that people might not have access to
because they're too expensive
or because they just don't have
a store anywhere near them.
So I just get really excited about it.
And I look at technology
and what it can provide.
It's endless opportunity.
The rise of resale now is akin to
that of e-commerce 20 years ago.
The field is wide open. The
front runner has yet to emerge.
No wonder it is attracting
billions of dollars
of investment.
It's a similar story of
upswing over in London.
So we went to Lille, we visited
with Vestiaire Collective
to learn about the luxury
part of the resell market.
Now we're here in the heart of east London
to learn about the mass end of the market.
We're here to meet with Depop.
They are a technology company here,
and they've had their own
journey during the pandemic.
And we're here to meet
with their CEO Maria Raga.
Depop is skewed towards lower
price products exchanged
between younger traders, almost
all of them 26 and under,
and who are attracted
to the community aspect
that a peer to peer platform can offer.
What makes a community
focused platform like Depop
different from typical fashion e-commerce?
From the very beginning,
when you think about the way
the app has been designed,
it has been designed with that in mind.
It's not just a place where
you come to find an item
that you want.
It's a place where you come
to discover other people
doing other things.
Where you can actually
interact with the users,
and then you can also engage
with them in real life.
And so for us, having this
community-first appeal
was extremely, extremely
important from the very beginning
and it has translated into
how we build the product
and also how we do marketing.
There's a huge overlap
of buyers and sellers
in the platform.
And that really creates
that sense of community,
it's not like a B-to-C model,
it's really a peer-to-peer
where people start as a seller
and then also become a buyer
and it basically fosters
the sense of community.
But what about the brands in your world?
Do you have engagement with those brands?
Yeah.
So we've been quite lucky actually,
because we didn't have to go
out there and talk to them.
They actually came to us,
initially because they
wanted to get access
to our community.
They see, as we see,
that Gen Z acts and behaves
in a completely different way.
And so, they wanted to collaborate with us
to understand that movement a bit better.
They also want to get
more involved in resell.
Especially now that has
become much more prominent.
They're trying to see
what's their place there.
And so for us, we were super welcoming
because we know that alone,
we're not going to change
the world for better.
So we need to work together.
How did the pandemic impact
supply on the platform?
And are there lessons you can learn
about how to get more
and more people aware
that actually they have
assets in their wardrobes?
The pandemic made people realize
that they had a lot of
things in their closets.
Marie Kondo was also quite
good on showing people
that you've got too much.
I think it was a moment in
time that made people realize,
wow, this is an issue.
On the back of that,
there's obviously a lot
more social consumption.
So people are realizing that
there's far too much out there.
If you think about the amount
of items being produced
on a yearly basis.
100 billion.
It's crazy.
That's like, what more than
250 million items a day.
So I think people are starting to realize,
maybe a pandemic had to happen
for people to notice that.
Supply drove the demands
because people were
listing all these items,
they were talking about it in social media
and then people were
coming to, oh, let's see.
And so in terms of what we can
learn from that, it's about,
not mimicking what happened
because you don't want
people to be at home, right?
So it's about reducing the frictions
that they found out on the way.
So like, how do we make sure
that we connect with buyers
and sellers in a better way
so that they don't have to
be looking at multiple items?
So one of our core areas of work right now
is personalizing the app
and really making a big difference
between the browsing experience
and the search experience.
Okay, so while all of this craziness
of a pandemic is going on,
you announce that you've
been acquired by Etsy.
What was it? For $1.62 billion?
So basically two years ago, we met them
and it was very much like a
knowledge sharing session.
And some of the things
that we ended up doing was,
on the back of some of the conversations
that we had with them,
I realized that first,
there's a lot of similarities
in Etsy and Depop,
in terms of values, if you will.
So they really, really
foster entrepreneurship
and creativity.
And they also really believe in consumers
that are community led.
More than 2 million users
joined the Depop community
in 2020,
proving the rapid trajectory
of the fashion resale market.
I met with Fiona Short and Youth,
two long time Depop sellers.
Nice to meet you.
How are you?
I've heard all about you.
Both have built their own businesses
to capitalize on this opportunity.
Now you're both in this market
that they're calling the
fashion resale market,
and you guys are Depop sellers,
how do you define the market?
Within the community,
we don't tend to use the
word resellers for ourselves
because what we do is
much more than reselling.
It's curating, sometimes
you're fixing pieces.
In fact, some of the pieces that we buy
are dead stock pieces,
and haven't even been
sold to a consumer before.
The term resellers, we use
more for the drop culture.
So we just tend to call
ourselves vintage sellers
or vintage dealers.
Yeah, there's so much to this industry
or whatever you want to
call it, this community.
I feel like you can have
so many different interests
and whatever you do day to day,
whether it be photography or styling,
or whether you like hiking,
they always come through
in your vintage curation.
So even though we do resell,
and that is a big part of it
and it keeps us going and
it allows us to carry on.
I think the main core part of it
is who we really are day to day
and what inspires us and our experiences,
where we come from and
what we really stand for.
Okay. So I have a little
challenge for you.
Okay.
I bought this t-shirt,
it's the first thing I ever
bought on the internet.
Wow.
Okay.
Like the first piece of
clothing I ever bought
on the internet.
I think I bought it in 1999 or 2000.
Would this have any value?
If this was from like a concert or a tour
or something like this,
the price of this would be a lot higher.
So this is double stitching,
which means it's made after 1992.
But if it's single stitch,
then it's before 1992,
which means it's going to
be worth a lot more money.
Can you show me the kind of
stuff that you guys sell?
Yes, of course.
Absolutely.
On Depop, and explain
to us why it's valuable.
This is actually the very first piece
that I picked up from
the markets in Italy.
€1, €1 everybody.
€1.
€1. It's a John Galliano top, right?
It's just a top.
Is it a bathing suit?
It's a bathing suit.
Beach wear, I believe
it's from the early 2000s,
newspaper print, iconic John Galliano.
And how much could that sell for?
I mean, you know more about John Galliano,
but, I believe £110, maybe £90.
Maybe, yeah, yeah.
All right, Youth. What about you?
I bought this at a market
and it's a Betty Boop Versace print,
which is one of Gianni
Versace really iconic prints.
What year do you think this is from?
This is like late 90s.
It's got double stitching.
There was one that was like early 90s,
which was single stitching,
but this is a later version,
but this has come back
into pop culture through,
I think Cardi B wore an all in
one Versace with this print.
And it's Betty Boop and a guest, Madonna.
So where does this market go from here?
How do you see the
resell market developing
and how might that
impact the way you manage
and run your own businesses?
Personally, I see this already expanding.
There's people who are
starting in their bedroom,
selling that own clothes.
And gradually now going into wholesaling.
As the industry does get more saturated
and people do want to get
involved in different ways,
there are obviously
windows that are opening
and doors that are opening.
Yeah.
I think one of the things
that I like so much
about this industry,
is that it's based on independent sellers,
individuals that are in their bedroom.
The new thing isn't now
to get a paper round,
it's to get your clothes on Depop.
And I think that we're going to see
so many young, young, young people
are starting their businesses
and growing really fast.
I think that it's just going to become
even more of a social norm
because remember like 10 years ago
when secondhand clothes wasn't cool.
It was counter-culture.
But now, as the coin's flipped
and it's became mainstream,
Fiona sold to Bella Hadid before.
You have?
Yeah.
What did she buy?
She bought two really
beautiful 90s vintage tops.
They were really reasonably
priced. They were beautiful.
They were just on the Depop,
available to everybody.
And I didn't even know
it was actually to Bella.
And then I saw it on her Instagram.
She was wearing it.
Yeah.
She could get anything she wanted
and she actually sought products out
that she couldn't get anywhere else.
Yeah.
That's really cool.
Well, the most interesting thing for me
is that people are
building real businesses
and livelihoods on these platforms.
They've created these whole
new models of interacting
with customers.
In the next 10, 15, 20 years,
as consumers become more comfortable,
and these platforms grow in visibility,
I think it's really going to transform
the way a lot of customers
engage with the fashion business.
It's not going away.
The market is going to grow massively
over the next 10 years.
There's huge amounts of inventory
sitting in all of our closets.
It's just about getting that
inventory and circulation,
getting brands to accept that
this is a permanent fixture
of the market going forward
and increasing the visibility
of these platforms amongst customers.